it's a special edition of pft pm and
joining us on this wednesday afternoon
the general manager of the buffalo bills
a team that hadn't been to the playoffs
for a very long time but once brandon
bean took over in 2017 two out of three
years to the postseason entering year
four and brandon joins us now good
afternoon brandon how's everything
that's good mike you know just uh
getting used to uh quarantine life as we
all are the new norm
what's been the strangest part of the
adjustment for you
just uh you know it's march and you know
we're in april now but it just it feels
like where did march go we're usually on
planes trains automobiles in and out of
hotels from pro days to privates and and
you miss the interaction you know we've
bounced to learnings learn how to use
zoom and facetime and all these other
features that we're even using right now
but uh
you do miss the the personal one-on-one
interaction with the players you know up
close we're having to you know do it
technology-wise
yeah no pro day workouts no private
workouts no in-person meetings no visits
from players which of those three things
is the is the biggest one the hardest
one to lose as you prepare for picking
players coming up in a couple of weeks
you know um you go i go back and forth i
really miss the 30s you know the guys
that we can bring into our facility and
just
let a lot of people in our building
touch them so to speak from uh the guy
who picks them up at the airport to um
you know your pr staff to the coaching
uh your trainers just you know one of
those things i like is i spend 15 20
maybe 30 minutes with the player but
he's there all day and so i'll circle
back with a lot of our staff and just
how was their interaction with him was
he personable was he professional was he
on time did he communicate well to our
travel staff you know just learning who
this individual is beyond who they are
in front of me or sean mcdermott
that's one of the things that fans don't
realize and players don't realize
especially in their early 20s when they
get in the car right from the airport to
the facility whoever's driving is
listening watching paying attention to
everything and we'll report back on how
that individual behaves and it's amazing
how few of those guys are prepared
to be the same guy that they're going to
be when they show up in your office
and and to be that same person within
the backseat of the vehicle being
chauffeured from the airport to the
team's headquarters
nah it's fun and you know what i've
found is sometimes the guy picking them
up at the airport or the hotel pick up
one or two other people with them and
and see who interacts with him who
doesn't even want to talk to him you
know who's griping about their coaches
from their college uh who's happy with
their agent or not happy with their
agent just you know is a certain player
is he complaining about everything or is
he just appreciative of the opportunity
those are the little things that uh we
probably will lose in this process
well you know and it's funny now uh if
we ever do get back to normal and who
knows at this point we're we're letting
out some secrets the agents are going to
tell the players to act like they've
been given the miranda warnings we're in
the back in the back of the car now
they're gonna finally realize that
they're paying attention to everything
that they're saying and doing for you
personally being at home now trying to
do all of this stuff not at the facility
not traveling but confining your house
what's been the hardest part of that
adjustment
you know um i think the hardest thing
right now is is we're doing our meetings
with our scouts and uh we're starting to
include our coaches a little bit just to
get their feedback
and you know we usually like to watch
film this time of year together if we're
arguing over you know two or three
linemen let's say and you know we're not
settled on well let's let's pick two
games where maybe they played similar
opponents or they went against the same
defensive end or defensive tackle and
let's just watch them against some of
the things because these guys come from
different conferences different uh
different playing levels so
i think that's one of the things that we
found
you know you just can't do it i cannot
watch group film with everybody because
it just doesn't work over the technology
so we've had to improvise as all 32
teams have but at the end mike i think
we'll still we'll still be fine and
we'll get to the right answer
i've had some folks tell me they
actually prefer being at home because
you don't have to worry about people
showing up in your office you don't have
to worry about noise outside your office
you can actually focus on your work now
some people working at home can't get
anything done because their families are
everywhere that they go what's that
balance been for you being able to focus
on your work but also deal with the fact
that you're home with your family
yeah it's definitely different i told a
couple of our people in our media last
week when i was talking to them i've had
i got two high school boys mike so uh
it's not that i have to worry about
changing diapers or anything like that
but
i've never had this many lunches and
dinner you know in the month of march or
april with them you know usually it's
only the month that we're off before
training camp that you're around them
this much and uh so it's been fun you
know i got one that's gonna be a senior
next year so you realize man this uh i'm
not gonna be able to spend this time so
i've tried to turn it into a positive
uh from that standpoint
and i'm curious brandon especially with
a kid who's in that that
age group and you know you feel a
different way life is different you're
you're more inclined to feel like you're
invincible you're immortal you can do
anything and then all of a sudden the
bubble gets popped with this reality
that has dropped on everyone's head it's
got to be a tough adjustment for a kid
it's got to be just that that cold
splash of water what would have been the
challenges of trying to get him to
understand that you know at a time when
he's living life to the fullest or at
least trying to he's got to stay home
all the time
yeah i think it's hard because uh he
plays football and he doesn't have a
spring sport but uh just you know they
do seven on sevens and you're not around
your teammates uh this is the time of
year they can get in the weight room and
lift and just same thing that that our
players are missing so i think
those are the things you know does he
miss the school work i doubt it they're
having to do everything remote online
like like we are but uh i i know even
though he won't admit he misses school
uh you definitely know he misses his
friends and the camaraderie like we all
do like we miss being in the workplace
before we get much farther i want to
shine a light on the great things you're
doing with the united way in your area
because
one of the things that dawned on me last
week when the news came out that the
patriots had gone through all the hoops
necessary to get 1.2 million and 95
masks from china it dawned on me we all
have a way that we can make a difference
in our communities and we can do it in
different ways at different levels but
as long as we find something to do
that's the positive that comes out of it
and you found a great way to help out
your community tell us what you have
going on
yeah so uh mike same thing i was trying
to figure out you know obviously i'm not
a medical worker or a front line type
person for for something that we're
dealing with but uh you you figure out
what donation you're comfortable making
and then beyond that it just doesn't
feel like it's enough so you know with
the help of derrick and my pr staff and
our community relations department you
know they came up with some ideas and so
we're going to try and give some
experiences you know along you know with
the draft of one of the prizes i think
will be really cool for whatever lucky
fan wins it will they're going to be on
the phone with me when we call our first
selection uh which will be in the second
round since we traded the first one but
um that and then after the draft is over
i'm going to have a one-on-one zoom call
with with a fan and just talk through
each pick that we made mike and how we
came to that decision and you know we've
got a couple other things once we get
back to to norm with uh a lucky fans
gonna be able to bring some guests to
have lunch with me at our ad pro center
and then um one's gonna be able to come
to practice and we've got some
memorabilia josh allen jersey and a
couple other things
and how can folks get more information
about this if they want to get in on is
it is it an auction or is it a raffle
so what it is is all you have to do is
donate it's it's wnyresponds.org
if you go to that website no matter what
five dollars ten dollars twenty dollars
if you donate five dollars or you donate
five hundred dollars no matter what
you're able to contribute you're in this
raffle and it's it goes mike until april
17th
i look at one of the prizes on here one
of the winners gets four 100 level
tickets to the bill's 2020 home opener
and i know that that's still months down
the road but from your perspective what
kind of information have you gotten what
kind of ideas do you have as to whether
or not there is going to be a home
opener and if there is one whether or
not fans are going to be in attendance
yeah i think it's still too early mike
you know we haven't been given a lot of
information you know at our level i
think every it's still such an unknown
as you were mentioning earlier like
where are we on the mountain on this
thing when do we when do we get the top
and and head back the other way so i
think right now everyone is just playing
as if we're going to try and have a
season i think a lot of that to be
determined you know how many games is a
16 game season is it less um will fans
be able to fill the you know will you be
able to have 70 000 will you be able to
even have 10 000. i think all those uh
are a lot of the unknowns but
you know my focus has really just been
on the draft mic and and that's coming
up here in a couple weeks after that i
think i will start to dig in and see
what it looks like
let's talk about the draft one of the
concerns that i saw raised by i believe
it was ravens coach john harbaugh the
possibility that zoom video conferences
can be hacked other information can be
pilfered electronically how realistic is
that possibility in your estimation
yeah i do think it's realistic you know
i think there's ways you know i learned
the other day
if you're using zoom they have waiting
rooms and password protected so i think
that will help you know what you read in
the news where some people were hacking
into some of these school uh zoom
classes and and doing certain things so
i think we have to be mindful of that
you know i've already spoken with dan
evans rit guy i've already i've told dan
he's going to be the mvp of this draft
since it's a virtual draft at home if if
the technology is not working
we're in trouble but dan is researching
uh different ways and what is the most
secure means for me to contact with my
scouts my ownership my trainers whoever
i need to talk to
i'll tell you what brandon one thing
that i've been saying about that if any
team out there tries to take advantage
of these unprecedented circumstances and
why we're in this position to turn that
into
a way to cheat a way to find out
information that they have no business
of getting and they get caught they
should get the worst punishment that the
nfl ever meets out because we're in this
predicament because of the greatest
public health crisis of our time and if
someone tries to cheat that system
because of why we're here they deserve
everything they get
i couldn't agree more you know there's
no tolerance for it and
would be totally unacceptable especially
in a time like this as you said mike but
nobody asked for this situation we're in
to be drafting like this
hey brandon there's been a lot of talk
about how technical issues may or may
not impact the draft and there's been
reporting that if there's any type of
technical difficulty for a given team
hey too bad there are other ways to get
the picks in but my understanding is if
there's a complete and total breakdown
if you if you have a generator outside
your house that gets struck by lightning
or whatever the case may be and you just
lose power that the nfl isn't going to
say too bad we have to keep going can
you give me an understanding of what the
rules will be if there is some
catastrophic technological breakdown and
a team like the bills just can't get a
pick in
you know mike they haven't explained but
i know to this point there is going to
be some type of dry run and i think
those questions will get answered i mean
at the end of the day
i think the league has to you know have
an option if if all else fails you lose
your wi-fi you lose your power uh to be
able to use your cell phone and call in
a pick and i think it'll be important
for everyone to you know to have a
backup plan if you do lose power uh you
know to have your board manually with
you just in case technology does fail
and what kind of technology are we
talking about everybody's got wi-fi in
their house now is there to be like the
old hard-wired internet with the
ethernet cord that plugs into your
computer as a backup to the wi-fi uh
because i i'm just trying to think of
everything that could come up and i
think the nfl needs to be thinking about
everything that could come up and one
thing is wi-fi goes down you want
hardwired internet as that fallback
yeah i think you do have to have
something to that sort again i'm not a
the most tech savvy guy mike but uh i
know my i.t guy has been at my house as
much as me lately just trying to sort
through what's the best options you know
and where to run cabling and things like
that for these backup plans whether it's
a generator uh backup wi-fi hardline all
the all the things that you would need
should something go wrong
how much time will you spend practicing
how this all unfolds when you're on the
clock if you need information from a
specific person a button to press a
person to speak to just almost like a
conductor of this process i assume
that's what your job will be but you're
going to have to get a lot of different
information in real time how much of
that will you rehearse and practice in
advance of the draft
no mike we definitely will you know i
think the week of uh definitely by that
monday you know our draft board will be
set um you know we usually try and set
it close to a week out but definitely by
that monday prior to the to the start of
it on thursday we'll be doing a lot of
dry runs with everybody that's involved
again from the scouts to the coaches um
to my medical staff uh security if i got
any any questions there just everybody
involved and again obviously my i.t guy
dan evans uh he's gonna have to be there
every step of the way
the uh
the length of the draft it's been seven
rounds i think since 1992 or thereabouts
used to be 12 before that it was even
more kevin colbert reportedly suggested
recently that three more rounds be added
this year because of the difficulties in
gathering information any position by
you on whether or not there should be
extra rounds you know uh i understand
kevin's point and and listen kevin's got
a uh way more seniority than i do so um
if if he really wanted that and there
was a lot of push for it i would support
it you know i'm operating mike that you
know it's going to be seven rounds like
normal and i think the biggest change
will be you know used to when you're
doing free agency like that um after the
after the seventh round you've got
everybody still in your draft room or at
least down the hall now trying to
communicate because you only have have
so many dollars that you can allocate
from a bonus and so a lot of times you
got several deals going and once you
agree to one you got to pull out of the
others if you're chasing you know an
offense if you're chasing three tackles
hoping to land one
if you've offered fifteen thousand to
one and and maybe you're talking twelve
thousand the other uh but you don't want
them both once you get one in the boat
you gotta kind of back out of the other
so it's a moving target i think that
will be um you know an obstacle for all
teams as we work through it remotely
and it's going to be even harder to
allocate those dollars for the signing
bonus for the undrafted players because
you're not going to have the same level
of confidence
in the information and the study and the
work up for those guys that didn't get
drafted so as much as the draft is a
crap shoot i feel like undrafted free
agency is going to be even more of a
crapshoot this year
yeah i think you're right because you
know one of the things is is we don't
have the medical the true medical of
these non-combine guys and um you know
guys that maybe suffered an injury this
season you know a torn ligament a
shoulder anything like that mike that uh
we haven't been able to see the player
or bring them in or or get you know our
hands on them uh those would be guys
that i could see potentially falling you
know either on our boards or other
team's boards
and then there's the reality that the
off season programs aren't going to
start i personally think at this point
there won't be any off season programs
how do you get your guys ready for a
season and i know you were in carolina
the last time this happened with no
off-season programs in 2011 coach
rivera's first year but how do you get
guys ready how do you get undrafted
players ready how do you get anybody
ready if you don't have an off season
program
yeah it's hard uh you know they're
working through this now with the pa mic
and and you know having virtual meetings
maybe you can meet for two hours uh
using the same things these zoom
technologies or teams or whatever um but
the you know i think the real hard part
mike is gonna be the workouts the
physical part of it how do you you know
train for speed how do you do you know
some guys live in apartments they don't
have room for you know even a bench you
know to lift heavy weights and your big
your big guys your linemen they need to
lift weights those are probably the guys
i worry about the most just having you
know the um the accessibility to weights
and and bars and things like that not as
much as the skills i think the skills
can get out and use bands and and find
fields to run in and things like that
but uh it's definitely not not an ideal
scenario and it will be a true test you
know if we don't have an off season
program come august let's say we do
start in august
to see who's most prepared because in
2011 there were a decent amount of
injuries you know achilles came to mind
and i believe acls were up that year so
uh a lot will tell on who was truly
working this time when when it's it's
truly voluntary when the draft begins in
15 days you won't be making a pick in
round one unless you trade back in
you've given that first round pick to
the minnesota vikings as part of the
stefan diggs package what will you be
doing the first round of the draft since
you're not going to be on the clock
well i joked again mike with the media
today we may put up some stephon diggs
highlights or something just
i'm looking at that as our pick because
um you know we talked about what would
be available at 22 and and again decided
to to trade some assets um to move up so
again i'm looking like stefan is our
pick and and we're you know we'll we
won't be in round one but uh we'll be
ready for round two on friday night
well brandon here's the point i made a
couple of years ago when the cowboys
traded for amari cooper near the end of
his rookie deal the reality is you give
up first round pick for a player who is
a veteran and is on a second contract in
digs
situation i mean you've got him for four
more years but it's relatively high
salary and at some point he's going to
want to reopen that deal and get himself
a raise what's your policy on when you
will go back and redo a deal that has
multiple years left in this case four
more seasons left on the diggs contract
yeah i mean i think you know those
things if you trade for a guy sometimes
you do make uh you know an agreement uh
with a player i've been involved with
before where you trade for them and you
say hey we we will do something to the
deal now we'll do something to the deal
in a year or whatever so again those are
discussions that you know we'll keep
between us and the age and the player
but um you know we do think you know
that was attractive to have stefan under
contract for four years and that was
part of of why we made this move uh you
know to try and acquire them and we just
at the end of the day mike we thought
that um
you know with the off season being you
know either limited or no off season
what we would be able to get at pick 22
might have a harder time coming in
helping us this year versus a proven
veteran like stefan
and from time to time stefan had i don't
want to say issues in minnesota i mean
look every receiver wants the ball and
sometimes when they don't get the ball
they get upset and i think the vikings
did a good job of keeping that under
control it could have been worse we've
seen other situations where it has been
worse what did you do brandon to get to
the point where you were comfortable
that stefan diggs isn't going to be any
type of an issue any type of a problem
in your locker room
well i mean obviously you never really
know mike until you get them in there
but um you know our scout our college
scouting director terence gray uh was in
minnesota when they drafted stefan and
was around him for a year i believe
and then we have some coaches at least
one uh on staff that's that's close with
with one of stefan's college coaches and
and knows a couple people so we did some
recon and um again
you know i understand the question i
think it's fair and and you alluded to
it um receivers want the ball and
sometimes
they express that and it can come across
in the wrong way and again we we feel
good we think he's a very competitive
young man
my understanding is he trains very hard
practices he raises the level of
competitiveness and practice and i don't
think you can have enough of that and
you know i think our culture you know
will be good for stefan and we look
forward to to bringing him in i know
josh allen has has been communicating
with him a lot and those two are looking
forward to
getting together and getting on the same
page
chris sims and i were talking the other
day about your draft needs and we
debated the status of devin singletary
obviously a guy you drafted last year
allowed you to move on from lashawn
mccoy but you know i look at singletary
as a potential workhorse sim's position
is maybe it's going to be a platoon
going forward and maybe you need some
some complimentary help well how do you
view devin singletary moving forward is
he a workhorse tailback for you or do
you envision having multiple guys who'll
be sharing the load
you know i think devin can can do either
or he's an unselfish player mike but i
think he if we want him to be the
workload guy i think he could definitely
do it i think year two is gonna be
better for him he had the hamstring
injury early in the year which which
cost him i think if he had not missed
those three or four games
he really could have pushed it closer to
a thousand yards and again i think he
can do it we're always looking for
competition though too so uh if the
right guy was there uh we wouldn't
hesitate to adam but again if we roll in
you know we feel good with t.j yellen
behind them uh tj started some in this
league and is a versatile three down
back as well uh so we feel very
comfortable with those two uh you know
as we head in
you know the importance of a franchise
quarterback you had one in carolina you
have one now i believe in josh allen and
he's only going to get better and better
cam newton's been available for the last
15 days or so how surprised are you
that the 2015 nfl mvp one of the best
quarterbacks in football when healthy is
just out there and there's been no one
linked to him in the two weeks since
he's been a free agent
yeah it's it's not something i would
have never seen i don't know if it's i
think it's partly due to the situation
we're in and as our country because
he's had you know two years where he
wasn't fully healthy and missed pretty
much all last year i think there is some
concern there and you know i think camp
sometimes can be a little misunderstood
uh but i'm a cam newton fan mike and and
uh i hope that uh i believe he's earned
the right with what you mentioned he's
an mvp and and again i probably wouldn't
be sitting in this seat if it wasn't for
cam newton and the success we had in
carolina that's how you you end up in
head coaches or gm positions so uh very
appreciative of cam and and i do think
in the end you know sounds like maybe
they're waiting until after the draft to
see where some of these quarterbacks
land um to give him a shot to to start
and i think he's going to come back with
a chip on his shoulder assuming he's
healthy
i wouldn't be surprised if he's if he's
not starting for somebody in 2020.
and if i'm a gm with another team and
i'm trying to figure out what to do with
cam newton and and and i've determined
he's healthy we've done the physical
right but i'm concerned about his
ability to stay healthy if i call you up
and i say hey brandon give me a sense
should i be worried with all the
injuries we've seen from cam newton over
the years his playing style you know
very physical should i be worried even
if he's 100 right now that he's not
going to stay 100 for long
no i mean i think at the end of the day
i think cam has adjusted his style i
don't think he he even before he he
injured you know the shoulder and all
that i don't think he was running as
much as he was in you know 13 14 and 15.
i think you know my last year in
carolina was 16 and you know he got hit
a couple times early in that season in
the denver game and you know he's he
stopped running as much at least it
seemed to me that he did so i think cam
again i think he will adjust his style
and and i think he just needs a you know
a chance i think honestly mike the kid
you know he's got a chip on his shoulder
uh i think he just needs an opportunity
you've said that the patriots are still
the team to beat in the afc east and i
understand that but there are a lot of
people who disagree and they think the
pendulum is swinging to the buffalo
bills how big of a challenge and look i
know we got a long way to go before
we're thinking about games and there's
so much to do between now and then but
how do you process that as an
organization how do you balance this
reality that there's gonna be a lot of
people that look at the buffalo bills
and say
now's their time to take that next step
and really take over this division
yeah it's a good question i understand
it but you know i think off seasons and
and things like that are you know are
one on paper they don't mean anything uh
just like our 10 wins mike last year you
know last year is in the past you know
this is a new season uh once it happens
a new team and until you knock off the
champ uh you're not the champ and i know
miami and the jets will be thinking the
same as us somebody's got to try and
chase the patriots uh and again bill
belichick is still there and this guy
won you know that team in 2008 won 11
games with matt castle you know who
really didn't have any success anywhere
else you know but that season so you
know they're gonna he's gonna you know
figure it out who who his quarterback is
they're gonna play sound defense they've
got a lot of players there i just i find
it you know as i said last week i find
it comical that people are writing them
off i understand on paper what things
look like but until somebody beats the
patriots they're the champs
and look for every team except the team
that wins the super bowl the last game
of the season is a disappointment your
disappointment came in the wild card
round and i want to spin this into a
positive based upon your review of the
game against the texans
what comes out of there to you what
stands out as the thing that you could
take to josh allen and say
here's what we can use as the impetus
for taking your game to the next level
yeah i mean i think
the one thing that that i look at is if
you're when your season ends early
unless you're holding up the trophy you
know especially if you make the playoffs
usually how you lose that game in the
playoffs usually is is an indicator of
what your issues were during the season
and our issues mike where we just we
couldn't consistently score enough
points and you know we looked at wide
receivers uh at the trade deadline we
weren't able to you know agree on a deal
or anything like that but i just felt
like we still needed someone opposite
john brown and cole beasley and hence
the move for diggs um but i think that
will help josh you know i think late in
that game uh josh probably tried to do
too much at times and and that's what
you love about him he's a competitor he
is not afraid uh you know to have the
ball in his hands you know at key
moments and and so i'm not upset at josh
young at all i think he was just trying
to do too much at times and again we
settled for field goals too often in
that game where we should have got
touchdowns and and i think another
weapon like you know stefan diggs and
and you know any other pieces that we're
able to add will only help our offense
going forward
hey brandon i appreciate so much your
time i know you got a lot to do we wish
you all the best as the draft approaches
and if you're bored the first night give
me a call i'll just be hanging out
drinking a beer watching it just like
you the first night of the draft uh
congratulations on the success so far on
the stefan drake diggs trade we're big
fans of stefan and we think you got a
great one there and we hope to talk to
you again down the road
thanks mike keep your family safe
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports